what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in you what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet I
started the mentum II series with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than us try to hang out
with people who have had more success in
us and hopefully some of their beliefs
some of their mindset some of their way
of working seeps into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're gonna learn from Malcolm
Gladwell and his outliers advice mentor
me Malcolm rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best also as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below I
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
[Music]
you
an outlier if you do some sort of
scientific experience experiment there's
this thing out there that destroy this
aberration that is way off the charts
and that's an outlier right yes that's
right okay so let's talk about some
outliers one of the one of the examples
of success you used in the book of The
Beatles yeah right tell the story of the
Beatles and why they defy the norms and
why they were as successful as they were
well I was really taken by this what
happened to them before they came to
America you know they they come here in
64 is the Beatles invasion blow explode
but before they came they were the house
band in a strip club in Hamburg Germany
right and they would play eight-hour
sets
seven days a week four months at a
stretch sure and the idea there is that
it was that we think of them as these
geniuses who just came out of nowhere
and who are naturally brilliant but in
fact they put in an apprenticeship of
thousands of hours these are four night
successes aren't overnight success at
all yeah that's one of the big themes of
the book actually is that we we said
look of people we think that they must
have this great innate talent and we
forget the enormous amount of work that
went into to what looks like genius
there's a principle I talk about in the
book called the 10,000 hour rule which
says that in a wide variety of
disciplines from being a good doctor to
be a great golf golfer or what it
doesn't matter really what it is it
looks like we need to spend 10,000 hours
practicing before we get good right so
there's never been a great classical
music piece of classical music when I
posed by someone who hadn't spent 10,000
hours or write about Mozart and
everybody talks about Mozart composing
is a little kid I didn't really compose
anything anybody cared about it until he
was what 23 at which point he'd been
composing for over ten years
oh yeah so it really really does make
sense
I remain I'm uninterested in that topic
and Tom which one whether the
relationship between gift and practice
no I'm not interested in natural gifts
yeah I know they exist and I know
there's such a thing as talented as know
that but right I just feel like so and
so what right because there are people
and I always think of your about coffee
and I always think of Derek Coleman yes
I remember chatting with a guy who
worked for the Sixers and he said you
have to understand the Derrick Coleman
was the most gifted man ever to set foot
on a basketball court he said I could
you know you've heard another a million
other names
nobody was as good as Derrick and like
who has heard today who thinks who puts
Derrick Coleman up there in the pantheon
no one he didn't want to work he had bad
habits he had a bad attitude I mean so
what give me somebody who wants to go to
practice in the morning and it wants to
try in games and I want to celebrate him
when you put forth effort you get reward
when you throw your heart and mind and
soul into something you get something
back now in my book I call that notion
that belief that effort brings reward
meaningful work and when you look at the
lives of people who are really
successful what you see over and over
again is this idea of meaningful work is
embedded in their consciousness you know
I tell the story of the book of um of
the Beatles everybody knows about the
Beatles they come here in 1964 and the
British Invasion the most interesting
thing about the Beatles is what happened
to them before they came to America in
the 1960 and 1959 when they were just
kids they went they were invited to go
to Hamburg in Germany to be the house
band at a strip club and they went there
and they stayed there for months on end
and seven days a week
they played eight-hour sets
night after night in this strip club
right and over the course of that
extraordinary crucible that experience
of playing they taught themselves how to
be a great band right in fact we know we
think now that by the time the Beatles
came to America they had played together
as a live band 1200 times we could go to
all of the clubs on Friday night in San
Francisco or all the promising young
bands are playing I submit to you would
not find a single band that is played
together 1200 times right just doesn't
happen so what made the Beatles special
what made them special is that they were
willing
to play together 1200 times willing to
play eight-hour sets
seven nights a week four months at a
stretch and why were they willing
because they believed in the notion of
meaningful work they had an opportunity
to throw their heart and mind into
something and get something back and
that made all the difference in the
world and to my annoyance some reviewers
of my book have accused me of being a
cultural determinist in fact I'm the
opposite so the culture that we come
from is the only deterministic of our
behavior if we choose to ignore it right
if you never address so that the chapter
that I was talking about in that in my
talk the plane crash chapter it's really
about Korean air and how Korean air goes
from being an airline that almost gets
pushed out of business because it has so
many plane crashes to being one of them
now what is now today one of the premier
airlines in the world and they transform
themselves in the law over the last ten
years precisely because they say they
decide at long last to confront their
cultural legacy and deal with it and
what they discover is if they are honest
and open about the fact that in this
particular instance the cockpit being
acting like you're a Korean is not a
good idea then you can change it and
they do they take that airline from
literally it was this close to being to
not existing anymore and it is now an
absolutely world-class airline and what
they what they showed and I continue
this theme in the second half of the
book is once we can talk about and
confront culture we can change culture
we're not prisoners of it
we're only prisoners of it if we pretend
it doesn't exist I had a conversation a
couple weeks ago I was out of giving a
talk and I was seated next to a guy who
ran a regional bank in Akron Ohio and I
said to him I was talking about as
business how's your business your
banking business he said oh we're fine
in fact we're more than fine we're about
to beg by a big bank in Chicago I said
why are you fine and no one else's and
he he was an older man he's probably in
his late 60s and he said I've been
through this three times before and what
I suspect we've talked a bit and I
suspect that he got humbled
25 years ago or in the early 70s or late
70s and never forgot that lesson and
it's that kind of it is in times like
that that we we understand why
experience and learning from experience
is so important you know it's more than
simply that word is not a kind of
meaningless triviality experience
matters because there's certain kinds of
things that you only learn when you when
you've been humbled right
you can't just explain to a 28 year old
things are going to get bad they're not
it's not going to sink in but to this
man I was speaking to who you know saw
it firsthand and dealt with it and I'm
I'm sure went through a manner of crises
before it's a lesson that he kept with
him you know Colin Powell before the
Iraq war was the he was the in-house
skeptic why because he'd been through
Vietnam you know you know in a very
first-hand way in a way that man of the
other decision-makers had not and had
never forgotten those lessons so there's
a there's another sort of case of
someone who appropriately was humbled
and learned from from experience and
you've got to have people like that
around all my work is about storytelling
but using stories to kind of get at
deeper truths but fundamentally I'm a
storyteller and every you know in
revisionist history every one of the
episodes is a story it has a and and
it's not it's not me ranting on about
this or that the other thing it's we
meet in really interesting people and we
tell their stories and use that as a way
of and that's a theme in all of my work
because I I think that the way into
complicated ideas is through people and
their stories thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you learn from this video
what clip spoke the most to you and how
are you going to apply it immediately
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
also if you're leaving a comment within
the first few hours of this video going
live you have
chance doing one of two daily prizes I
also want to give a quick try to -
Joshua Rodriguez from the Josh speaks
thank you so much man for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and doing
that fun collaboration on your channel
together to showcase the book I really
really appreciate the support man and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the read I feel
so honored to be able to directly pass
this video along to Evan so that he can
share his ideas on what it means to live
a life of purpose which ultimately is
all about being your best self thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]